hilft das ja auch wenn man etwas
pragmatisch vorangeht und wir können
damit auf den nächsten Antrag schauen
der jetzt hier besprochen wird die
afd-fraktion hat einen Antrag zum
zum Ukraine Krieg eingereicht in diesem
erfordert sie die Entsendung einer
internationalen Friedensdelegation
unterleitung der OSZE nach Kiew und nach
Moskau damit mit beiden Regierungen über
einen sofortigen Waffenstillstand
diskutiert wird
außerdem hat sie in diesem Antrag noch
weitere Forderungen eine 90-tägige
Feuerpause soll es unter anderem geben
zum ersten besprechen
Damen und Herren ich bilde mir nicht ein
Sie mit unserem Antrag von der
Notwendigkeit einer Friedensinitiative
überzeugen zu können
dazu stecken sie schon viel zu sehr in
reinen militärischen denken fest
doch sie werden vor den Menschen
begründen müssen warum immer mehr und
immer stärkere Waffen den Weg zum
Frieden Ebenen sollen
statt Diplomatie soll es der Leopard
richten heute sind es Kampfpanzer morgen
kampflugzeug es wird bereits darüber
diskutiert und übermorgen vielleicht
Nato-Soldaten auf ukrainischem Boden
es darf keine roten Linien geben tönt es
aus Kiew und natürlich hat die Ukraine
und unsere Geschäfte Diplomatin
beschäftigt sich damit eine Partei vor
einem sonder
tribunalanklagen zu lassen statt Tag und
Nacht nach Auswegen aus der Krise und
Möglichkeiten zu Waffenstillstand und
Frieden zu suchen
Zitat aber ohne ein politisch
strategisches Gesamtkonzept sind
Waffenlieferungen Militarismus pur diese
Einschätzung stammt vom
militärpolitischen Berater der früheren
Bundeskanzlerin Fahrt und der
amerikanische generalstoffchef geht
davon aus dass ein Sieg der Ukraine
nicht zu erwarten sei und das
Verhandlungen der einzig mögliche Weg
sein
doch einem Handeln entsprechen dieser
Einsicht steht die westliche Annahme
entgegen
des Putin die Ukraine auslöschenwolle
also kein Kompromiss möglich sein
in ernsten Verhandlungen meine Damen und
Herren ist diese Annahme nie geprüft
worden und auch die
Sicherheitsinteressen Russlands
gegenüber der NATO gelten im Westen nur
als vorgeschoben ohne sie einem Test
durch Verhandlungen zu unterziehen
meine Damen und Herren es ist Zeit dass
wir das endlich tun
und statt auf einer schiefen Ebene immer
stärker in Richtung eines europäischen
Krieges oder gar einer aus atomaren
Auseinandersetzung zu rutschen
wo vorher selbst der UN-Generalsekretär
inzwischen gewarnt hat
meine Damen und Herren
unser Antrag bietet dazu Wege
mehr und besseres ist immer möglich
nur die Richtung müsste Stimmen
weg von einem Sieg der einen und
Niederlage der anderen Seite
weg von der militärischen Logik
es darf diesen Krieg keiner gewinnen und
nur wenn wir das endlich
akzeptieren und für eine friedliche
Lösung arbeiten hat der Frieden eine
Chance
ohne die Einsicht dass eine militärische
Lösung nicht zustande zu bringen ist
wäre auch der 30-jährige Krieg nie zu
Ende gegangen hoffentlich
dauert es bei uns nicht so lange ich
bedanke mich
alexander gauland hat hier die Debatte
um den Antrag der afd-fraktion eröffnet
wunderschönen guten Tag von meiner Seite
auch an die Besucherinnen und Besucher
auf den Tribünen und wir führen die
Debatte Fortune das Präsidium hat auch
gewechselt jetzt hier diese Sitzung in
nächster Redner ist Ralf Stegner für die
SPD-Fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen ein Jahr tot
und Zerstörung ein Jahr Vertreibung
Vergewaltigung Kriegsverbrechen ein Jahr
Kälte Angst und Traumata für Frauen und
Männer für junge und Alt für
Zivilbevölkerung und Soldaten ein Jahr
russischer Angriffskrieg auf die Ukraine
und das einzige was die AFD zur Debatte
beizutragen hat ist eine schlechte Trump
Kopie mit dem Slogan unser Land zuerst
die demokratischen Parteien vertreten
unterschiedliche Ansichten wie wir die
Ukraine am besten unterstützen können
aber in einem sind wir uns völlig einig
wir verurteilen Russlands Völkerrecht
gegen die Ukraine und europäische
Friedensordnung wir nehmen nicht hin
dass in Europa Grenzen mit Gewalt
verschoben werden und wir unterstützen
die Ukraine deshalb ja
Selbstverteidigung politische ökonomisch
humanitärisch
was macht die AFD ihre
Bundestagsabgeordneten fahren zu
fragwürdigen Veranstaltung auf die Creme
sie reisen zu Putins Marionettenregime
nach Belarus sie treten in Propaganda
Talkshows im russischen Fernsehen auf in
den ungeniert zum Mord an unserer
Außenministerin aufgerufen wird das eine
schandendes widerwärtig meine sehr
verehrten Damen und
sie fordern das nordstream 2 wieder in
Betrieb genommen wird als wäre nichts
gewesen sie sagen dass die Ukraine uns
nichts angeht uns Deutsche mit verlobt
dass es blanker Nationalismus ohne
Empathie für die Ukraine und Ukraine die
von Putin Schergen jeden Tag angegriffen
sie sollten nicht chemisch hat solche an
Unsinn hier zu verbreiten meine sehr
verehrten Damen und Herren
das ausgerechnet sie von der AFD sich
nun als eine Friedenspartei inszenieren
an der Friedensinitiative in ihrem
anderer fordern das ist nun wirklich
verlogen und perfide ausgerechnet sie
schwatonieren davon Deutschland soll es
eine historischen Verantwortung für
Frieden in Europa gerecht werden von
echter historischer Verantwortung wollte
ja Verein noch nie was wissen sie sind
berüchtigt werden
Geschichtsrevisionismus ihre Leute
relativieren immer wieder den Holocaust
kürzlich haben ein paar Kollegen hier im
Hause
Hause bedauert dass bei der
Gedenkveranstaltung ich muss Ihnen sagen
ich vermisse hier keinen rechtsradikalen
wenn wir der
Opfer des Nationalsozialismus gedenken
meine sehr verehrten Damen und Herren
Sie Herr gauland haben die Zeit des
Nationalisten Nationalsozialismus
öffentlich als ein vogelschiff in über
1.000 Jahren erfolgreicher deutscher
Geschichte bezeichnet da legen Sie
gemeinsam mit dem russischen Botschafter
am Jahrestag der deutschen Kapitulation
von Stalingrad einen Kranz nieder sie
demonstrieren sie Solidarität mit einem
Kriegsverbrecher 80 Jahre nachdem der
Nazi Terror dafür verantwortlich war das
in Steininger hat 100.000 im Zweiten
Weltkrieg insgesamt Millionen von Opfern
zu beklagen hat das nennen sie
vogelschissischer Gesetz überhaupt nicht
meine sehr verehrten Damen und Herren
Nationalismus war die Quelle
schrecklicher Kriege im letzten
Jahrhundert und es gilt auch heute noch
ihr abgestandener nationalismus ist doch
das Gegenteil von friedliche
Außenpolitik die einzigen Begriffe die
ich in ihrem rechten Meter politischen
Wörterbuch und da lesen sind
Abschottungen Ausländer Hetze sie feiern
sich in diesen Tagen für zehnjähriges
Bestehen was feiern sie eigentlich ihr
unterirdisches Benehmen diesen Parlament
ihre Fake News reden oder ihre
permanente Hetze gegen MigrantInnen
Migranten oder ihre versuchen die
Demokratie hier zu definieren was
bedeuten 10 Jahre AFD möglich sie
bedeuten sie haben für alles ein
Sündenbock und für nichts eine Lösung
das ist AFD
sie werden von Verfassungsschutz als
rechtsextreme eingestuft
Verwaltungsgerichte bestätigen das sie
sitzen hier obwohl sie ihre Plakat und
Werbekampagnen in illegalen parteispänen
finanzieren lassen sie sitzen hier und
ihre ehemalige Bundestagsabgeordnete
Birgit meister-winkelmann sitzt auch und
zwar nur Untersuchungshaft weil die
gemeinsam mit Mitglieder der
reichsbürgerszene einen Anschlag auf den
Deutschen Bundestag vorgenommen hat
erlauben sie eine Zwischenfrage aus der
afd-fraktion
meine sehr verehrten Damen und Herren
auch die Prozessen vor 100 Jahren in
München war zu viele gestalten das kann
nicht der Punkt sein wir müssen
aufpassen dass unsere Demokratie nicht
gefährdet wird mein Kollege Sebastian
Hartmann hat es auf den Punkt gebracht
sie sind die Feinde der Demokratie fast
genau 90 Jahre nach der mutigen Rede von
unterwegs gegen das Ermächtigungsgesetz
sage ich ihnen wir Demokraten ganz
besonders wir Sozialdemokraten erkennen
die Feinde der Demokratie wenn wir sie
sehen und da drüben sitzt sie mag ihre
Thüringer höcke noch so treu hat sich
twittern Frieden schaffen ohne Waffen
ein Slogan übrigens den von der Fasten
linken Friedensbewegungen geklaut hat
derselbe höcke tritt gemeinsam mit einer
rechtsextremen Gruppe von vorbeschaffen
Kriminellen in Gera auf da kommen
zusammen was zusammengehört meine sehr
verehrten Damen und Herren und der höcke
gehört weder ein Parlament und erst
recht nicht von der Klasse von
geschichtsstudenschülern meine Damen und
natürlich ist kein Zufall dass Sie
Wladimir Putin verteidigen ihm geht es
nicht
um die Bevölkerung
jetzt ist ihre Sympathie sie verbünden
sich von der AFD Jugend mit der
russischen Jugend der jungen Garde ihre
Parteifreunde von Frauen national freuen
sich über die Rubel mit denen dort die
Rechtsextremisten in Europa unterstützt
werden das sind Gesinnungsgenossen von
ihnen deswegen reden sie hier so nicht
weil es um Frieden hier meine sehr
verehrten Damen und Herren
nein nach rechtsradikale Partei braucht
uns nichts zu erzählen über Frieden
übrigens Frieden ohne Demokratie und
Freiheit endet noch Soldatenfriedhöfen
das ist die Lehre des 20 Jahrhunderts
meine sehr verehrten Damen und Herren
die Ehefrau ihres Kumpanen Kubitschek
hat sich wie folgt geäußert ihre Partei
charakterisiert die Schlange sie heute
sehe ich sie heute sich wieder bis alle
wieder braune Farbe sehen so Frau
Kubitschek das ist genau das was man
sieht wenn man bei ihnen hinguckt das
ist nämlich eben zum Schluss eines sagen
es gibt drei Dinge die sich nicht
verändern lassen Intelligenz Anstand und
eine Mitgliedschaft in der AFD man kann
intelligent und afd-mitglied sein dann
fehlt einem der Anstand man kann
vielleicht sogar anständig und
afd-mitglied sein dann ist man auch
besonders intelligent man kann wie die
meisten hier anständig und Intelligenz
sein dann ist man definitiv nicht
Mitglieder der AFD man sagt sie sind
keine
sie sind keine Alternative für
Deutschland sie sind eine Schande für
Deutschland und nach zehn Jahren gilt
mehr denn je nach 10 Jahren gilt mehr
denn je wir werden nicht ruhen bis die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger wie in meinem
Heimatland Schleswig-Holstein dafür
gesorgt haben sie nicht mehr Parlament
sitzen weil das ist
ihren Klumpen antiag
[Applaus]
ukraine-antrag den
verschieben wir zwar in den Ausschuss
aber ich kann Ihnen sagen was das
Schicksal am Ende sein wird solchen
unproblem wieder Demokraten hier im
Deutschen Bundestag ab sehr viel
herzlichen Dank
Ralf ist Stegner war das mit Einlassung
zum Antrag aber doch auch einer sehr
generellen Ansprache an die afd-fraktion
die Partei feiert ja gerade
zehnjähriges Bestehen Knut Abraham
spricht nun für die Unionsfraktion
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen ich bin heute wirklich
außerordentlich dankbar hier sprechen zu
können denn ich möchte mich
entschuldigen entschuldigen beim
ukrainischen Volk entschuldigen für die
Anmaßung dieses afd-antrages er habe
etwas mit Deutschlands Verantwortung für
Frieden in Europa zu tun ihr sogenannter
Friedensplan ist ein völlig
durchsichtiges innenpolitisches Theater
Liebe Ukraine das ist nicht Deutschland
das ist nur die AFD
kein Wort des Mitgefühls in ihrem Text
kein Wort des Mitgefühls mit dem Opfern
des russischen eroberungskrieges selbst
die selbst die völkerrechtswidrigkeit
der Aggression wird zwar genannt aber
vernebelt und relativiert die EU sei zu
schwach gewesen den Krieg nicht
verhindert zu haben schreiben Sie die EU
der unglaublich damit schieben sie
subkutan die Kriegsschuld von Russland
auf die EU und dann geht's weiter hoch
interessant sie kritisieren die ich
zitiere finanzielle und und ideologische
Unterstützung hören Sie doch zu ihr Text
Unterstützung
oppositioneller Gruppen die habe zu
wachsender Instabilität und Spaltung in
einigen Staaten geführt ja die
Demokratie Bewegungen redet Belarus hat
was sie beklagen zu wachsender
Instabilität des Lukas Schenker Regimes
geführt und das ist gut so und meine
Damen und Herren von der AFD merken sie
nicht dass sie mit diesem Vokabeln die
alte Termin wieder SED bedienen die
haben immer gesagt Finanzierung aus dem
Westen und Ideologie aus dem Westen sie
benutzen sed-vokabeln
meine Damen und Herren apropos Belarus
wo es eigentlich der Abgeordnete bistron
ist der wieder in Belarus zu
besonderer Operation bin mal gespannt
sehr eigenartig wir haben ja gestern
erfahren dass sie sich von 16 bis 19
November bei Herrn Luca Schenker
offenbar aufgehalten hat was hat er da
eigentlich getan warum berichten Sie uns
nichts darüber aber zurück zu den
Unsäglichkeiten Ihres Textes es ist eben
kein russisch-ukrainischer Konflikt im
Tonfall einer Familien
Auseinandersetzung es ist ein Angriff
Russland auf sein friedliches
Nachbarland das wissen sie auch passen
sie auch das wissen sie auch ich habe
ihn was mitgebracht das wissen sie auch
noch im November hat ein Positionspapier
ihres Arbeitskreises außen klar
formuliert es sei ein
völkerrechtswidriger Angriffskrieg
Russlands den wir Schaf verurteilen sagt
ihr aka und weiter Zitat wir trauern mit
den Familien der gefallenen Soldaten
dann vor lauter Unfug aber immerhin aber
nichts davon findet sich in ihrem Antrag
keine Wahrheit kein Mitgefühl
stattdessen veranstalten sie ein
friedenskonzert gestern Abend offenbar
also das hat mir schon mal geschockt
dass ich die Einladung sah noch
geschockter war ich dass sie gastieren
Herr
also ich weiß nicht wie das gewesen ist
wahrscheinlich nur eine Show denn ginge
es ihnen wirklich und das propagieren
von Frieden dann hätten Sie Herr Porträt
Sie Herr Porträt sich im russischen
Fernsehen vor einer Woche in der
hass-sendung des Vladimir Salome dazu
äußern können sie haben es aber nicht
getan sie haben nicht von Frieden oder
ein Friedensplan oder was immer
gesprochen auch Sie Herr Schmidt gleiche
Reihe da oben 15 Kolonne sieht immer 17
Reihe
auch Sie Herr Schmidt hätten vorgestern
bei ihrem propagandaauftritt bei Rossija
1 Gelegenheit gehabt für Frieden und für
den erforderlichen militärischen Rückzug
zu werben haben sie aber nicht sie
meinen ihren eigenen Text gar nicht
ernst sie sprechen von Frieden aber in
Russland sind sie fester Bestandteil von
Putins Propaganda und damit auch mit der
Kriegsmaschine
ist Ihnen Herr gauland eigentlich gar
nicht bewusst wie sehr sie unserem Land
Schaden und was Sie für eine tragische
Rolle dabei eigentlich spielen
meine lieben Kolleginnen und Kollegen
hören Sie doch zu es gibt einen
Friedensplan es gibt einen Friedensplan
und zwar seit 1990 die Kater von Paris
und seit 94 das Budapester memorantum
diese Verträge gelten dazu braucht es
den
vollständig haben
sie eine Zwischenfrage des Kollegen
Falle nein
wirklich nicht also Erbarmen bitte nicht
dazu braucht es den vollständige Rückzug
der russischen Truppen aus allen
Gesetzen Gebieten der Ukraine und das
ist keine Forderung das ist die
Rechtslage nochmals an die Ukraine und
auch die die wenigen die mutigen die
sich in Russland im Widerstand befinden
dieses Papier ist nicht Deutschland aus
diesem Papier spricht Putins Moskau und
dessen Berliner Hilfstruppen und deshalb
lehnen wir diese Zumutung ab vielen Dank
abraham war das hier in der Debatte zum
Antrag der
afd-fraktion
ingophale ist mittlerweile ja
fraktionslos durfte aber auch keine
Zwischenfrage stellen damit kommen wir
zum nächsten Redner das ist Jürgen
Trittin
es gibt eine kurze Intervention die
Möglichkeit einer Kurzintervention
ich will es auch wirklich Entschuldigung
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin ich will
es sehr kurz machen
die Reden die letzten zwei reden aber
besonders die letzte wo ich mich jetzt
gemeldet habe die führt mich zu der
Frage wenn Sie eine Fraktion komplett
hier ausgrenzen und mit solchen
Unterstellungen Arbeiten worin
unterscheiden sie sich eigentlich von
früherer
göbelshop-propaganda gegen Minderheiten
sie sind doch die Hitze in diesem
Parlament wir wollen Frieden schaffen
und zwar auch ohne Waffen das ist meine
Antwort und Herr gauland hat genau die
richtige Rede gegenhalten und er hat
auch das gesagt was ich zum Ausdruck
bringen aber ich lasse mich doch hier
nicht eine rein in solche Klischees die
sie hier verbreiten wir meinen unsere
Politik Ernst jedenfalls ich auf jeden
Fall und ich lass mir sowas nicht
unterstellen mir tun die russischen
Soldaten leid mir tut die ukreichischen
Soldaten
bezahlt und ich möchte das jetzt endlich
friedensverhandlung stattfinden dass
diese Regierung mal was für den Frieden
tut denn mit Panzern hat noch nie eine
Frieden im Land geschaffen das ist genau
das Gegenteil dann sterben immer mehr
und immer länger noch Menschen und die
USA haben es langsam begriffen aber sie
werden erst begreifen wenn noch viel
mehr Menschen gestorben sind
vielen Dank für die Möglichkeit
[Applaus]
lieber
Robert fahle war das
wir wollen auch mittlerweile
fraktionslos aber ist über die
afd-fraktion hier ins Parlament gekommen
darum ihnen
[Applaus]
entschuldigen sie bitte lassen Sie mich
bitte zu Ende sprechen und zwar
und wenn Sie ein Problem haben mit
meiner Sitzungsleitung dann können Sie
das gern im Ältestenrat in der nächsten
Woche ansprechender das ist nämlich das
Gremium dafür und nicht diese Sitzung
heute hier Herr vorne ich erteile Ihnen
einen Ordnungsruf für euren Vergleich
mit der göbbelzeit
die Möglichkeit nach vorne sie müssen
trotzdem stehen bleiben weil nämlich der
Kollege Abraham jetzt die Möglichkeit zu
Antwort hat
alle sehr geehrter Herr Kollege Falle
sie haben ja offensichtlich gar nicht
zugehört ich habe diesen Antrag sehr
genau studiert und ich habe mich bemüht
in Zeile für Zeile zu analysieren und so
bin ich zu dieser Rede gekommen was dem
Antrag und das will ich noch einmal
sagen gänzlich fehlt ist das Mitgefühl
was bei ihnen wenigstens teilweise
aufgeschrieben ist danke
soweit die Kurzintervention von Robert
fahle und die Erwiderung von Knut
Abraham nun gehen und ist aber weiter
mit dem nächsten Redner das ist Jürgen
Trittin der außenpolitische Sprecher der
Grünen Fraktion
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
es ist manchmal schon schwer erträglich
dass jemand der jahrelang sich hat von
Ostberlin bezahlen lassen als
dkp-funktionär und dann zur AFD gegangen
ist hier sich in dieser Art und Weise
aufführen kann ich bin wenn etwas war
eines Beweises noch bedurft hätte was
die propaganda-rolle von ihnen im
Interesse Putins angeht dann war das
eben der Auftritt von Herrn
als ich den Antrag gelesen habe habe ich
gedacht ich kann irgendwie nicht ganz
wahr sein die AFD für Frieden seit wann
setzt sich die AFD für Frieden ein wenn
sie üblich und er ist jüngst wieder vor
flüchtlingswohnheim randalieren
setzen sie sich für Frieden ein wenn
ihre Ex-Kollegen mal sagt Winkelmann mit
ihren reichsbürger-kameraden Waffen
sammelt um den Bürgerkrieg in diesem
Land einzutragen
oder
haben Sie sich für Frieden eingesetzt
sehr Portrait als sie bei Wladimir
solowskiw im russischen Fernsehen
aufgetreten sind
der Herr
so läuft jetzt hat er nämlich einen Tag
vorher das gleiche gemacht wie der
Kollege fahrlehr hier eben er hat
sämtliche deutschen Journalisten und
Journalisten als Nachfahren von Goebbels
und entkommenen nazischweine tituliert
und am Tag drauf sind sie in der
gleichen Sendung bei dem gleichen Hetzer
aber anstatt diesen Entgleisungen zu
widersprechen haben Sie Herr Porträt das
auch noch bestätigt sie haben gesagt es
muss gesagt werden dass Journalisten und
Medien alles tun um die deutsche
Gesellschaft gegen Russland gegen die
russische Regierung aufzubringen und sie
seien entsetzt dass wieder deutsche
Panzer geliefert werden um Russen zu
töten
und jetzt bin ich bei Ihnen Herr gauland
ich ist schon eine Form von
Geschichtsvergessenheit den Charakter
der Aggression über die wir uns hier und
mit der wir konfrontiert sind zu
negieren
es waren deutsche Panzer
die Russen
Tschetschenien Georgia
[Musik]
überfallen haben im Zweiten Weltkrieg
und sie tun jetzt so
als wenn Deutschland sich in diese
Tradition stellen würde nein es ist
genau umgekehrt wo hat denn der
Angriffskrieg stattgefunden wann hat zum
ersten Mal seit dem Beginn des Zweiten
Weltkrieges auf dem europäischen
Kontinent eine macht andere Grenzen mit
Militärgewalt überschritten um etwas ja
zu erobern und sich dieses Land untertan
zu machen das war Putin das war Russland
mit dem Angriff auf die Ukraine und wenn
Sie wissen wollen wie dieser Krieg
geführt wurde wie dieser Krieg geführt
wurde dann schauen Sie sich die Berichte
an zu Butter und anderen da kommen einem
historische Assoziationen zum Vorgehen
der deutschen Wehrmacht der SS und der
Polizei kostet in der Ukraine in
Russland und anderswo davon hätte ich
von ihnen ein Wort verlangt
nein ich glaube sie sind nicht für
Frieden sie betätigen sich lieber als
propaganda-zwerge für die
Kriegspropaganda von Putin
was aber dahinter steht oder womit sie
sich kostümieren ist ja die Behauptung
man könne man könne über Verhandlungen
diesen Konflikt jetzt zu diesem
Zeitpunkt lösen ich bin der festen
Überzeugung am Ende wird es
Verhandlungen geben aber heute sind wir
in einer Situation
die sie
Herr gauland wenn sie mal nicht heimlich
Mein Kampf Schmökern würden sondern
Wilhelm Busch lesen
Sie das Gleichnis finden dann würden sie
das Gleichnis finden
vom Igel und dem Fuchs Herr Trittin
erlauben sie eine Zwischenfrage aus der
AFD nein
wenn und ich hoffe sie kennen dieses
Gleichnis Herr gauland da geht es
nämlich darum dass der Fuchs den Igel
auffordert sein Fell zu übergeben weil
der Friede längst verkündet sei und
dabei lässt sich seine Zähne leckt das
ist die Situation in der wir uns heute
befinden
wir müssen Frieden als Ziel unseres
Handels haben aber wir müssen klar
hatten dass dieser Frieden nicht
existieren kann in Form eines
einseitigen dikstats er beruht nicht auf
Wehrlosigkeit sondern ein gerechter
Frieden der ist mehr als die Abwesenheit
von Krieg das Konzept des Gerechten
friedenswies die evangelische Kirche
definiert hat das ist etwas was als
politisches Leitbild tatsächlich auch
ein Stück Wehrhaftigkeit mit voraussetzt
und deshalb ist es bitter deswegen ist
es schwer aber es ist notwendig die
Ukraine so auszustatten dass sie nicht
von einem imperialistischen Aggressor in
der Tradition von Eroberungskriegen
überrannt wird und dafür stehen wir
Jürgen Trittin war das für die Grünen
Fraktion
und vielleicht gibt es eine kurze
Intervention
einen Ordnungsruf zum Vergleich zu
meinem Kampf und jetzt hat der Kollege
Erhorn eine Möglichkeit zu kurz
invention
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter vielen Dank übrigens für
die Möglichkeit der zwischenintervention
sehr geehrter Herr Kollege Trittin wir
haben hier in den letzten Minuten
erleben können
teilweise Hass und Hetze wo werden sie
ja immer sehr viel und gerne reden
insbesondere vom Kollegen Stegner selbst
für ihn war diese Darbietung
unterirdisch es zeigt aber eins in ganz
besonderer Weise wie tief sie darüber
getroffen sind darüber getroffen sind
dass es inzwischen in diesem Deutschen
Bundestag nur eine einzige Partei gibt
die sich tatsächlich dafür verwendet
Friedensgespräche zu initiieren während
alle anderen Parteien unter anderem auch
ihre Partei die Partei der
Friedenstauben hier für mehr und mehr
Waffenlieferung für eine militärische
Lösung des Konfliktes Eintritt und von
sonst gar nichts
ich kann ihn nur eines sagen wenn es
hier im Deutschen Bundestag so weit
gekommen ist dass die einzige Partei die
sich für friedliche Lösungen und für
Diplomatie einsetzt von allen anderen
Parteien in diesem Hohen Hause
angegriffen wird dann muss ich Ihnen
sagen ist es fünf Minuten vor zwölf dann
ist es wirklich fast zu spät für die
Demokratie in Deutschland es ist
unterirdisch dass man selbst angefeindet
wird wenn man sich für Frieden einsetzt
und nichts anderes tun wir und davon ist
völlig unberührt dass es
selbstverständlich für alle Soldaten bei
der Parteien großes Mitgefühl gibt wie
natürlich auch für die zivilen
Bevölkerung die zu leiden haben es geht
uns darum dieses Leid so schnell wie
möglich zu beenden und das sollten auch
Sie verstehen vielen Dank
thomas ehrhorn war das aus der
afd-fraktion Jürgen Trittin kann nun
eine Erwiderung hier abgeben
wenn man für Frieden ist
warum hat ihr Herr Porträt
bei dem Auftritt den er hatte im
Fernsehen
sich nicht dafür eingesetzt warum hat er
nicht gesagt beendet euren
völkerrechtswidrigen Krieg das ist der
erste und wichtigste Schritt stellt die
Kampfhandlung ein
sie behaupten sie seien die einzige
Kraft der sich für Frieden einsetzt aber
wenn Sie die Gelegenheit haben sich für
Frieden einzusetzen im angesichts des
Aggressors dann ziehen sie den Schwanz
ein dann schweigen sie
und dann legen Sie uns hier Herr
Abrahams hat das vorgelesen ein Antrag
vor
der die Kriegsschuld Frage komplett
umdreht dann ist es nicht mehr Russland
die diesen Angriffskrieg geführt haben
sondern es ist das Angebot gewesen der
Europäischen Union mit der Ukraine eine
gemeinsame wirtschaftsbeziehung
einzugehen also etwas friedlicheres kann
ich mir überhaupt nicht vorstellen und
das benennen sie in ihrem Antrag als
Ursache für den Krieg in der Ukraine
nein sie sind nicht für Frieden sie sind
für Putins Krieg das ist das Problem
[Applaus]
bei der ein oder anderen Formulierung
die ich jetzt nicht wiederholen möchte
ja denken wir das nächste Mal bitte
darüber nach auch war die verwenden gebe
ich mal so an alle mit ein Stück weit
und von daher führen wir jetzt die
Debatte fort mit dem nächsten Redner
Fraktion DIE LINKE Ali al dalami hat
jetzt das Wort
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
erlauben auch sie mir eingangs etwas zu
Antragstellerin der AFD zu sagen das
ausgerechnet sie einen Antrag stellen
der Frieden postuliert und von der
historischen Verantwortung Deutschland
spricht ist gerade zu Protest denn eine
Partei die Faschisten in ihren Reihen
nicht nur dulte sondern auch hofiert die
über die schießbefehle an der deutschen
Grenze statt ruiniert und so wie sie
Herr gauland den deutschen Faschismus
mit seinen singulären Verbrechen als
Vorgeschichte der Geschichte bezeichnet
eine solche Partei sollte die Worte
Frieden und historische Verantwortung
nicht mal in den Mund nehmen sie ist
absolut unglaublich
doch erlauben Sie mir nun zur
Bundesregierung zu kommen je länger
dieser Krieg andauert umso mehr sitzen
sich leider in den Reihen der
Bundesregierung jene durch denen keine
Waffe zu schwer und kein Risiko zu hoch
zu sein scheint und so jagte in den
letzten Monaten ein Tabubruch den
nächsten was mit der Lieferung von 5000
gefäßhälmen begann hat seinen
vorläufigen Höhepunkt in der Zusage
Leopard Kampfpanzer liefern zu wollen
erreicht dabei haben die
wissenschaftlichen Dienste des
Bundestages unlängst festgestellt dass
bereits mit der Ausbildung ukrainischer
Soldaten an den zuliefernden Waffen der
gesicherte Bereich der nicht
Kriegsführung verlassen wird was im
Umkehrschluss also bedeutet dass
Deutschland Brot sich zunehmend selbst
zur Kriegspartei zu machen und das nenne
ich verantwortungslos
und der bisherige Fokus der
Bundesregierung auf die rein
militärische Logik droht Deutschland nun
auf die Füße zu fallen anstatt selbst
mal diplomatisch initiativ zu werden
überlassen Sie lieber einem dispoten wie
Erdogan das Feld als Vermittler in
diesem Konflikt Stichwort
getreideabkommen oder der Kopf
abdiktatur Saudi Arabien dort wurde im
letzten Jahr ein Gefangenenaustausch
ausgehandelt oder den Vereinigten
Arabischen Emiraten deren diplomatische
Offensive zur Wiederaufnahme der ausführ
russischen Ammoniaks führte sowohl Saudi
Arabien als auch die Vereinigten
Arabischen Emirate führen nun seit über
8 Jahren eine Verbrecherin des
verbrecherischen Krieg gegen den Jemen
ist es laut UN die größte humanitäre
Krise unserer Zeit mit fast eine halben
Millionen Toten und es sind deutsche
Waffen die an diesen
Menschenrechtsverbrechen beteiligt sind
ich denke deutlicher kann die
Doppelmoral aber auch das Versagen
dieser Bundesregierung ist sein meine
Damen und Herren
doch zum Glück baut sich international
zunehmend eine Opposition zu dieser
Kriegslogik auf die überwältigende
Mehrheit der Menschen aber auch der
Regierung des globalen Südens sind nicht
bereit sich an diesem Krieg zu
beteiligen und erst recht nicht die
negativen wirtschaftlichen Folgen für
die falschen Entscheidungen in Europa
und den USA zu tragen deshalb beteiligen
sie sich weder an den Sanktionen noch an
dem Waffenlieferungen und so führt der
Wirtschaftskrieg gegen Russland eben
nicht zu den erhofften Auswirkungen der
Bundesregierung sondern das Gegenteil
ist der Fall und werden ihre
Waffenlieferungen die sind letztlich
immer weiter in die Länge ziehen und
auch das ist absolut verantwortungslos
um jeden Preis wollen sie und versuchen
Sie die Länder des globalen Südens ins
westliche bootsherren doch daran besteht
und das nehmen Sie bitte mal zur
Kenntnis in Brasilia Neu Delhi praetoria
oder Jakarta nun mal kein Interesse und
die Abfuhr die sich Kanzler Scholz in
Brasilien zum Thema munitionslieferung
abgeholt hat war richtig und wichtig
brasilien ist ein Land des Friedens
kommt hatte Präsident Lula die Forderung
des Kanzlers und so entscheidet sich
dadurch aller Voraussicht nach das
Schicksal Europas weit entfernt von
dessen Grenzen und dafür tragen all jene
die Verantwortung die immer noch meinen
Panzer offensiven sein besser als
Diplomatie offensiven danke für Ihre
Aufmerksamkeit
soweit der stellvertretende
Fraktionsvorsitzender Ali dein Lamy für
die Linksfraktion für die FDP hat nun
Ulrich Lechte das Wort er ist aus dem
politischer Sprecher der Liberalen im
deutschen Parlament
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
dass ich eines Tages an diesem Pult
stehen würde und sagen würde dass ich
Ralf Stegner und Jürgen Trittin zu 100%
Recht gebe und ihre Reden unterschreiben
hätte ich in meinem Leben nicht für
möglich gehalten heute ist dieser
historische Tag denn seit bald einem
Jahr für Wladimir Putin und seine Russen
den völkerrechtswidrigen Angriffskrieg
gegen die Ukraine wie wir Tag und Tag
sehen sind die russischen Streitkräfte
nicht Willen sich an die
zivilisatorischen Mindeststandards
Verhalten die auf der ganzen Welt
Konsens sind die Russische Föderation
beschießt die Kraftwerke bombardiert die
Krankenhäuser und zerstört die Wohnung
jener Menschen die vom Moskau immer als
historisches Bruder Volk bezeichnet
wurden denn Russland so mit seinen
Freunden umgeht dann können Sie sich
vorstellen wie es mit seinen
vermeintlichen Gegnern Verfahren wird
falls Putin diesen Krieg gewinnt
Putins Krieg ist ein Angriff auf das
ukrainische Volk er ist aber auch eine
Attacke auf die regelbasierte
internationale Ordnung deshalb stehen
wir gemeinsam mit unseren Partnern
zusammen an der Seite der Ukraine um
Putin Grenzen zu setzen wenn wir den
Krieg
schon nicht verhindern konnten mit allen
diplomatischen Bemühungen da müssen wir
wenigstens dafür sorgen dass er nicht
Schule macht der Angriffskrieg darf sich
für Putin und seine Freunde hier in
Deutschland wie gauland und Co schlicht
und ergreifend nicht lohnen im Laufe
der letzten Jahre hatte Kreml seinen
Krieg gegen die Ukraine Stück für Stück
eskaliert er hat diplomatische
Vereinbarung vorsätzlich gebrochen und
internationale Vermittlungsversuche
sabotiert wer heute Sicherheitsgarantien
für Putin fordert
ignoriert damit die unangenehme Wahrheit
russland hat kein Interesse an einem
Frieden auf Augenhöhe sondern möchte
seine Bedingungen diktieren vor diesem
Hintergrund ist Ihr Antrag blanker Hohn
gegenüber dem Millionen Menschen die vor
dem russischen Terror fliehen mussten
interessanterweise die Hauptteil
Richtung Westen über 90 Prozent oder
jeden Tag Angst um Leib und Leben haben
die Ukrainer haben sich nach dem Ende
des Kalten Kriegs auf die
Sicherheitsgarantien der Russischen
Föderation verlassen und das drittgrößte
Atomwaffenarsenal der Welt aufgegeben
Kiew braucht Verbündete deswegen ist
eine EU-Beitritt hierfür auch ein
geeigneter Schritt denn wie sich gezeigt
hat macht valentinsneo imperiale
Außenpolitik nur vor einem glaubhaften
abschreckungspotenzial wie dem
Schutzschirm der NATO Halt und dem
Bedeutungsverlust Russlands hat Vladimir
Putin laut eigener Aussage nie verwunden
und den russischen
Minderwertigkeitskomplex gegenüber der
EU kompensiert der Präsident militärisch
für die Russische Föderation Stellen
demokratische Nachbarn mit guten
Beziehungen zum Westen eine Bedrohung
des eigenen Modells da so wird jeder
Versuch unabhängiger Staaten aus der
vermeintlichen russischen Einflusssphäre
auszubrechen vom Moskau drakonisch
bestraft und das ist der Fakt das
wichtigste außenpolitische Instrument
Russlands war ist und bleibt die
Erpressung und Energiesektor deshalb ist
die von der AFD geforderte
Wiederaufnahme der wirtschaftlichen
Beziehungen ein Fehler das ist ein hohen
das ist einfach nicht zu glauben wir mit
so einem Partner bei Pipeline weiterhin
verhandeln möchte hat den Ernst der Lage
offensichtlich nicht begriffen die haben
Wirtschaft Sanktionen gegen Russland und
die Waffenlieferung sind die wichtigsten
Instrumente der internationalen Allianz
gegen Putins angriffskriegs unsere
Hilfen sind der Grund warum wir heute
überhaupt über Friedensverhandlungen
diskutieren können der Antrag der AFD
offenbart ihre offensichtliche
Bereitschaft jede Aggression Russlands
in Europa hinzunehmen das ist offene
anbieterung an ein Regime das versucht
über Drohungen die Nachbarländer und
Kritiker einzuschüchtern statt sich
konstruktiv durch Diplomatie und Dialog
auf der Weltbühne einzubringen
und warum
weil Putins Russland in der Realität
weder eine gesellschaftliche Vision noch
überzeugende Ideen anzubieten hat die
Moskauer Eliten schwelgen immer noch in
der Erinnerung an eine glorreiche
Vergangenheit als Großmacht weil die
gegenwartung die Zukunft des Landes
derzeit sehr trifft sind die AFD sind
für Putin hierbei die treuesten basalen
die es in Deutschland zu finden gibt
abschließend möchte ich hinzufügen dass
wir stets bereit sind eine diplomatische
Lösung für diesen Krieg zu finden und
das Sterben zu beenden wenn Putin seine
Armee zurückzieht wenn das tägliche
bombatement aufhört falls der einen sich
zeigt und die Ukraine als souveräne
Demokratie akzeptiert denn das ist eine
Verhandlungsphase auf Augenhöhe und sie
haben davon wirklich keine Ahnung
herzlichen Dank
für die afd-fraktion spricht nun
Matthias in Moosdorf er sitzt im
Ausschuss für die Angelegenheiten der
Europäischen Union der Antrag ist ja
auch von der afd-fraktion hier
eingereicht meine Damen und Herren
keinen vernünftigen Menschen wird es
einfallen Tintenflecken mit Tinte oder
Ölflecken mit Öl Weg waschen zu wollen
nur Blut soll immer wieder mit Blut
abgewaschen werden Bertha von Suttner
starb 1914 in dem Jahr in dem Europa in
die Ursünde eines Jahrhunderts der Hölle
schlitterte niemand wollte das niemand
hält das für möglich denn allen
gemeinsam waren Dummheit Ignoranz die
Lust an der Provokation und angebliche
Bündnis Verpflichtungen und die mediale
Begeisterung obwohl der
Wissenschaftliche Dienst unseres Hauses
festgestellt hat dass man damit den
gesicherten Bereich der nichts
Kriegsführung verlasse bieten wir
ukrainische Soldaten aus schwere Waffen
und operative gefechtsdaten zur
Vorbereitung von Kämpfen liefern wir
schon lange mit Kurzsichtigkeit
Realitätsverweigerung und einem völlig
verrückten Werte Imperialismus steuern
wir nun wie UN-Generalsekretär gutjahres
warnt sehenden Auges in einen großen
Krieg sowas sieht in der Ukraine Zitat
ein Rammbock gegen Russland US-General
hoges sagt es liegt in unserem Interesse
wenn es zum Zusammenbruch oder zur
Balkanisierung Russlands kommt die
Russische Föderation soll in ihrer
jetzigen Form nicht weiter bestehen
US-General Mille möchte die Ostsee zum
Zitat Teich der NATO machen
selensky-berater polotti hat gesagt der
Krieg soll auf Moskau und Sankt
Petersburg übergreifen Zitat Ende Polens
premiermorawetzki fordert die
Zerschlagung der Russischen Föderation
das meine Damen und Herren ist
Kriegstreiberei geschichts vergessen
Grundgesetz widrig Ehre und
verantwortungslos und und Metalle Raum
zu sprechen es ist darüber hinaus ein
Fehler
Frieden für die Ukraine und Russland und
Frieden in Europa sind untrennbar
miteinander verbunden es wird ihn nicht
geben ohne die Fehler zu korrigieren die
mit der Erweiterung der NATO unter
Ausschluss Russlands gemacht wurden eine
europäische Sicherheitsarchitektur muss
mit Friedensgesprächen zwischen dem
Westen und Russland beginnen unsere
Geschichte die aufgeklärte Sicht auf die
schmerzvollen Erfahrung der letzten
Jahrhunderte haben aus Sicht der AFD
eine zentrale Bestimmung Kriege zu
beenden Frieden zu stiften Ausgleich und
Verständigung zu ermöglichen
Frau Merkel wird es sagen Pipeline
sprengen unter Freunden das geht gar
nicht
Emanuel macron
ich hoffe zufrieden möglich dass alle
Beteiligten an einen Verhandlungstisch
zurückkehren die Frage der territorialen
Integrität oder was auch immer muss von
den Menschen geklärt werden die dort
leben wir fordern die Bundesregierung
auf eine Friedenskonferenz einzuberufen
unter Beteiligung aller involvierten
Staaten und der UNO und der OSZE
versuchen sie den Frieden wie Nathalie
Bennett dessen Mühen sie offenbar
sabotiert haben ein Satz zum Schluss von
Berthold Brecht lasst uns die Warnungen
erneuern meine Damen und Herren denn der
Menschheit drohen Kriege gegen die
vergangenen wie armselige Versuche sind
und sie werden kommen ohne jeden Zweifel
wenn denen die sie in aller
Öffentlichkeit vorbereiten nicht die
Hände zerschlagen werden Frieden ist die
Basis von allen denn ohne Frieden ist
alles nichts vielen Dank
Matthias im Moosdorf war das für die
SPD-Fraktion spricht nun Alice Ahmetovic
er sitzt für die
SPD-Fraktion auch im Auswärtigen
Ausschuss hier zum Antrag der
afd-fraktion um die Erlaubnis der
Präsidentin zu fragen das war nämlich in
der gesamten Rede keines mal der Fall
ich bitte das in Zukunft wieder
einzuhalten
für die SPD-Fraktion hat das Wort der
Kollege Addis
amethovic
beides richtig gut vielen Dank
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin sehr geehrte Damen und
Herren liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
eines habe ich in der Schule gelernt als
Schüler falsche Aussagen bleiben falsch
egal ob sie geschrieben werden
gesprochen werden oder geschrieben
werden Herr mosdorf ihre Aussagen sind
falsch um bleiben damit auch falsch
vor genau einem Jahr durfte ich hier an
diesem Rednerpult meine erste Rede
halten quasi zum selben Thema nur wenige
Tage vor dem Einmarsch Russlands in die
Ukraine und dem Versuch das europäische
sicherheits- und friedensgerüst ins
Wanken zu bringen ich betone dem Versuch
ich habe vor einem Jahr formuliert ich
zitiere sollte es durch Russland eine
neue militärische Aggression gegen die
Ukraine geben muss Russland mit harten
Sanktionen und Reaktionen rechnen die
wir gemeinsam und geschlossen mit
unseren Verbündeten umgehend
verabschieden werden
Russlands perfider Plan in weniger als
einer Woche Grenzen innerhalb Europas zu
verschieben und die territoriale
Integrität einer souveränen Ukraine
anzugreifen so zeigt es sich nach einem
Jahr dieser russische Plan wird nicht
aufgehen meine Damen und Herren
der zweite russische Überfall auf die
Ukraine am 24 Februar 2022 hat jedoch
eine historische Zäsur erwürgt auf die
unser Bundeskanzler Olaf Scholz sehr
richtig und wegweisend mit einer
Zeitenwende reagiert hat wir
unterstützen als geeintes Deutschland in
einem vereinten Europa gemeinsam mit
unseren internationalen Partnern ein
souveränes demokratisches Land die
Ukraine und seine Bevölkerung die
Ukrainerinnen und Ukraine wir helfen
einer Demokratie die Teil der
europäischen Familie und es
transatlantischen Bündnisses werden
möchte und das liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen tun wir weil genau das unsere
historische und europäische
Verantwortung ist nichts anderes
unsere Unterstützung für die Ukraine
fußt auf vier Prinzipien erstens wir
unterstützen die Ukraine humanitär wir
haben in einer gesamtgesellschaftlichen
Anstrengung seit dem russischen Überfall
über eine Million geflüchtete in
Deutschland aufgenommen tausende Tonnen
Lebensmittel Hygieneartikel und
Bekleidung in die Ukraine geliefert und
helfen aktiv dabei die von Russland
gezielt zerstörte Infrastruktur Wärme
Wasser und Strom wiederherzustellen
zweitens wir unterstützen die Ukraine
finanziell deutschland ist der größte
Geldgeber der Ukraine innerhalb der EU
hat den Staat seit Kriegsbeginn mit
bilateralen Leistungen von über 12
Milliarden Euro unterstützen dazu
arbeiten wir schon jetzt mit unseren
internationalen Partnern eine Art
Marshallplan um der Ukraine auch beim
langfristigen Wiederaufbau zu helfen und
ja
wir unterstützen die Ukraine auch
militärisch die Lieferung deutscher
Flugabwehrsysteme an die Ukraine stellt
einen essentiellen Beitrag zum Schutz
der Zivilbevölkerung vor gezielten
russischen Raketenangriffen da ohne den
ukrainischen Kampfes Willen und
westlichen Rüstungslieferungen zu den
inzwischen explizit auch schützen und
Kampfpanzer zählen wäre Putin sein Ziel
sehr wahrscheinlich bereits ein Stück
näher ich sage ganz deutlich niemand hat
sich die Entscheidung zur Lieferungen
von Rüstungsgütern in die Ukraine leicht
gemacht ich nicht und meine Kolleginnen
und Kollegen auch nicht und das ist auch
völlig menschlich viele von uns bekommen
Briefe aus den Wahlkreisen von besorgten
Bürgerinnen und Bürgern diese Sorgen
nehmen wir ernst immer mehr und immer
schwerere Waffen sind eben kein
Automatismus und er keine
Selbstverständlichkeit in einem Alltag
eines Menschen dennoch und gerade
deswegen ist es so wichtig dass wir eine
Bundesregierung haben und Frau
Außenministerin schön dass Sie auch
dabei sind weil es auch ihr mit
Verdienst ist dass wir gemeinsam
besonnen Handeln gemeinsam mit unseren
Verbündeten uns abstimmen keine
Alleingänge zulassen und Deutschland
nicht zur Kriegspartei werden lassen in
diesem Rahmen sind Waffenlieferungen
richtig und notwendig sie dienen zur
Selbstverteidigung für die Ukraine und
erhöhen den Druck auf Russland zudem
steigert ist die Erfolgschancen der
Diplomatie unser viertes Prinzip
entgegen mancher Vorwürfe hier im Raum
bemühen wir uns als Bundesregierung seit
Tag eins um Diplomatie und
Friedensgespräche zur Wahrheit gehört
aber dazu jegliche internationale
Bemühungen und Diplomatie und
Friedenspolitik werden von Putin und
nicht von Europa werden von Putin
weiterhin sabotiert putin ist erst
bereit für Gespräche wenn das
ukrainische Existenzrecht ab erkannt
wird diese völkerrechtswidrige Position
stellt für uns keine Verhandlungsbasis
da da ist unsere außen
sicherheitspolitisch
sicherheitspolitische Strategie genau
richtig auf der einen Seite humanitär
und finanziell helfen und auf der
anderen Seite militärische Stärke und
Diplomatie zusammendenken wenn die Putin
Treue AFD wiederum heute einen Antrag
zur Verantwortung Deutschlands für den
Frieden in Europa vorlegt der einmal
mehr das fragwürdige
Geschichtsverständnis und Wissen der
Partei sowie auch ihre putinische
Position offen legt müssen wir als
Demokraten und Demokraten darauf ganz
klare Antworten finden ein Diktat
Frieden ein fauler Kompromiss oder ein
brüchiger Waffenstillstand so wie diese
Antrag es vorschlägt können für uns
keine Lösungen sein alle demokratischen
Fraktionen stellen sich dem entschlossen
entgegen es braucht viel mehr einen
echten nachhaltigen Frieden ein Frieden
der nicht über die Ukraine hinwegfahren
handelt ein Frieden der die Souveränität
und territorale Integrität der Ukraine
gewährleistet ein Frieden der die
Verantwortlichen für Kriegsverbrechen
wie in Botschaft oder Japan zur
Rechenschaft zieht das ist unsere
historische und europäische
Verantwortung meine Damen und Herren
am Ende wird es darum gehen und da bin
ich deutlich das Russland und Putin
diesen Krieg verlieren und gerne zitiere
ich unseren neuen
Bundesverteidigungsminister Boris
Pistorius die Ukraine muss diesen Krieg
gewinnen Zitat Ende ich fügen zu für
sich für Deutschland und auch für Europa
vielen Dank
und für die Unionsfraktion hat das Wort
die Kollegin Dr Katja leikert
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen das ist
wirklich eine unglaubliche Debatte heute
hier im Hohen Haus und das bei so einem
ernsten Thema der verkauft sich die AFD
jetzt also als die friedensfraktion wie
Herr kropalla es so schön nennt als die
einzige Kraft was eben in der
Kurzintervention gesagt wurde die für
Frieden in Deutschland und Europa steht
das muss man sich wirklich mal auf der
Zunge zergehen lassen den einzigen
lieben den es gäbe wenn wir ihren
Forderungen der letzten Monate gefolgt
werden das wäre in der Tat Kollege Armin
towitschatz gerade gesagt ein
diktatfrieden Russlands das wäre ein
bitterer Frieden der klar machen würde
dass das Recht des Stärkeren wieder gilt
in Europa und das liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen das werden wir nicht
akzeptieren
und wir lesen sogar ihre Anträge
Kollegen von der AFD sie schreiben ihrem
Antrag vom russischen Rückzug hinter die
Grenzen vom 23 februar von fairenfreien
Referenten im Don Bass und von
bilateralen Verhandlungen über die Krim
all dem soll Putin angeblich zustimmen
im Austausch für das Versprechen dass
die Ukraine nicht in die Nato und nicht
in die Europäische Union aufgenommen
werden und da fragt man sich wirklich in
was für einer Welt Sie leben als ob sie
ernsthaft glauben dass Russland sich
darauf einlassen würde sie sind doch
Putins beste Freunde wie glaubhaft ist
das denn
und dabei sie haben ich sitze ja da
ziemlich nah an ihnen tragen sie rufen
ja auch dauernd rein sie fordern Fakten
was passiert ist doch ganz
offensichtlich was Putin vor hat seine
imperialen Fantasien die liegen ja vor
Anfang des Monats drohte sein
Außenminister lawrov damit
Ihnen auch die baltischen Staaten
vielleicht fahren Sie da auch regelmäßig
hin werden regelmäßig bedroht ebenso
Schweden und Finnland und ganz zu
schweigen von Georgien kein keine Ahnung
was sie dazu sagen wo schon 2008
russische Truppen einmarschiert sind und
bis heute geblieben sind
Putin greift seit Jahren und das ist ein
Fakt Putin greift seit Jahren seine
Nachbarn an und wird dies auch weiterhin
tun sie brauchen auch nicht die Augen es
ist kein es sind keine Lügen das sind
Fakten und wir verlassen den Bundestag
an dieser Stelle für eine
Pressekonferenz in Brüssel ist
vorladimir selenski und wird